Welcome back it's Charlie this will be my full
Star Wars and or episodes one through episode 3
video they just released the first three episodes
the series is going to be 12 total I'll be doing
videos for all them so be sure to subscribe to
get those careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen them yet we'll start at the beginning and go
through shop by shot talking about Easter eggs WTF
moments as we go along and I will explain what's
going on just in general with the series because
most of you probably know this is meant to be a
prequel to the events of Rogue one like that's
what they say it takes place five years before
the Battle of Yap and that's what 5bby means
the events of Rogue one are meant to take place
right before the events of A New Hope with them
stealing the Death Star plans their whole plan
for this series is that this will take place
over the course of a couple years and then season
two will cover the rest of the timeline right up
to the beginning of Rogue one like the ending of
the Andor series will be the very beginning of
Rogue one and they've already confirmed it will
get a season two like they'll start filming it
sometime soon one of the other big differences in
this series is that it's going to be 12 episodes
normally the Star Wars Disney plus series
have been about Eight Episodes so love of
the expanded run wish they did more episodes of
the Mandalorian like the Mandalorian season 3 is
going to start in February it'll still be Eight
Episodes but the whole idea with this series is
that it's meant to show you how the Rebellion
formed because that's basically what's happening
at the beginning of Rogue one like the Rebellion
is already the Rebellion for the most part when
this series begins five years before that they're
still called the resistance like they haven't
become the actual Rebellion they're going to
show you how that happened like all the legwork
the behind the scenes stuff in how that actually
took place before the events of this series they
say canonically that there are three people that
were critical in the formation of the Rebellion
there's mon mothma who's a character during this
series you saw her a couple times in the trailer
bail Organa who will also probably show up at
some point during this series and then also
Princess Leia the only person I'm not sure how
they're gonna handle during this is Princess Leia
because at this point in the timeline I believe
that she has not become an imperial Senator yet
I don't think that happens for a couple more years
they had to recast a new young actress but it'd be
older than the version that we saw in Obi-Wan like
the little girl Leia if they did that then they
could recast another version we'll see how they
handle it but it's like with this series they're
trying to tell you that there's this fourth person
in the creation of the Rebellion named Luthen Rael
played by stellen Skarsgard who's really behind
everything like the person who got everyone else
on board all the important figures into the idea
of creating the Rebellion the actual series was
written by Tony Gilroy most of you will remember
him as the person who basically fixed Rogue one
and turned it into the movie that everybody
loves so much today like it's one of the better
Star Wars movies that they've done since Disney
bought Star Wars they actually just signed him to
develop more Star Wars series Beyond this more
live-action Series so we don't know what those
are going to be but it should be pretty cool but
when I started making this video like when they
first uploaded the episodes to Disney plus they
didn't have actual titles on the episodes they
were just called episode one episode two episode
three they might add actual titles later just
starting with the events of the first episode they
start with the title screen in the brand new Andor
theme they did have different theme music that
they did for each of the episodes in the actual
opening title scene the planet that they start on
I believe is meant to be the canary planet that
he's from originally and it morphs into the symbol
of the Rebellion because the whole series is about
the creation of the rebellion and because they
go to so many different brand new planets that
we haven't seen in Star Wars before with a few
exceptions like they mentioned a couple familiar
planets but a lot of them at the beginning of the
series here are brand new they give you a lot of
title cards a lot of text to explain where you
are when you are on the timeline so in the opening
scene casting Andor is on the morlana one planet
within the pre-ox morlana corporate Zone which is
basically like a group of planets in a system that
a corporation owns this pre-ox borlana Corporation
it's in the mid Rim but they want to show you that
they're like a lot of large corporations out there
that control big parts of the Galaxy that also
have to operate within the purview of the Empire
like the Empire Still controls everything but the
whole idea is that you have a lot of like really
large corporations who are also pretty terrible
like the Empire terrible but corporations also
pretty terrible too who want to have nothing to do
with the Empire like there's a whole thing during
the episode we don't want them up in our business
it is bad for money so like even this terrible
corporations hate the Empire but the first couple
of episodes take place on a couple of different
planets that this Corporation controls and he's
coming to this planet trying to track down his
sister that we see in the flashbacks the canary
woman that he's looking for that he was separated
from like the little sister he was separated from
when Marvaa basically took him or rescued him from
the Republic I'll explain the timeline with those
flashbacks too like when is this taking place when
are these flashbacks happening how old is he in
present day but they make it seem like this is
just meant to be the CD underbelly red light
district of this corporate owned town when he
passes by the first alien it sounds like she's
speaking hadees in this whole first part of the
episode it's just meant to show you some of the
quote-unquote terrible things that Cassian Andor
did in his past that he references during the
events of Rogue one later like he says I've done
terrible things and he winds up killing these
corporate people to try to shake him down they
just want to show you that the people who helped
form the Rebellion also did terrible things in the
formation of the Rebellion just like the empire
did terrible things so even though some of the
figures in the Star War Universe are meant to seem
like truly good people like Luke Skywalker Leia
Organa meant to seem like truly good people most
of the regular people like Cassian Andor these are
the like Rank and file Rebellion people also did a
lot of terrible stuff very morally gray when they
start talking about the kenari planet they treat
it like it's this huge deal meant to be this huge
secret Cassian has been keeping his entire life
ever since Marvaa saved him when we start seeing
the flashbacks though I think that's meant to take
place a little bit after the events are around the
events of phantom menace just based on how old
he seems I believe he's meant to be in his 30s
now like Diego Luna who plays the character is in
his early 40s but this is taking place earlier in
the timeline from Rogue one so that's why I say
he's probably in his 30s and I think the flashback
version of him is just meant to be like early
teenager maybe a little bit younger than that so
like this would be before the events of the Clone
Wars when the ship is crashing so that's why they
keep referring to the Republic ship that's coming
to investigate the crash marvaa also kind of makes
it sound like the Republic is going to do some
shady things too like are going to round up all
those kids and arrest them because they killed
that Republic officer the weird thing about his
backstory that they don't completely explain
yet like we'll probably figure out the rest
of it later but the Imperial records state that
it was an imperial mining planet that they just
mined for resources where there was an accident
that rendered it hazardous for human occupation
so nobody can go there anymore they don't make
it clear if it's meant to be a cover-up and it
was this particular ship crashing because like all
the regular looking people have yellowed skin like
there was an accident and that's what turned their
skin yellow but clearly these characters are all
running around the ship and they're totally fine
so it sounds like it's a big cover-up and I think
the idea is that when the empire was formed they
just took over the planet and they claimed that
it was an imperial Mining facility and whatever
was going on on that ship it was just something
super secret I think the reason why Cassian kept
his identity secret for so long the fact that he
was from that planet is because Marvaa drilled the
fear into him that the Empire would hunt him down
for killing that particular officer even though he
himself wasn't really to blame for that but there
could be some something larger going on in the
flashbacks they haven't fully revealed yet you
can let me know in the comments if you think it
was just like that one thing the way they showed
us in the episode or if there was something else
that's way more secret that they haven't fully
revealed yet but I think the whole idea with
the Empire sweeping that under the rug in the
past is meant to dovetail with the officer in the
present who tries to sweep the murder of the two
officers under the rug most of the places and the
things that they talk about in the first couple
of episodes are brand new stuff that they created
for this series like there's a couple things that
existed before but for the most part it's all
brand new stuff although the hallways in this
Cantina that he walks into do kind of look that
they're shaped like a star destroyer then after
he kills the guards we go to the farrix planet
which is also within the same system that the
same corporation owns but it seems like most
the planet is used for General Scrap Processing
the brand new Droid character is named B2 emo
we also see him in the flashbacks way shinier
in the flashbacks too they'll be selling a toy
of him soon if they aren't already he's voiced
by Dave Chapman who's also done voice acting in
Star Wars before he did the voice of bb-8 in the
sequel movies and he also worked on the Rogue one
movie obviously that's the sequel to the events
of Andor so big connection there it shocks one
of the animals that's pissing on it R2D2 style
and when it says that this is inside the free
trade sector like I explained there are parts of
the Galaxy that corporations control and they're
kind of neutral but kind of not at the same time
like they still have to pay a lot of taxes to the
Empire and they service the Empire's requests but
mostly they're there serving their own corporate
interests like that's what they care about more
than anything so it's just an area of the Galaxy
that the Empire doesn't directly control like they
only get involved if things get really crazy which
makes it easier for people like Cassian people
like luthin still on skarsgard's character who
are trying to create this Rebellion to actually
operate that's why you have a lot of characters
like Ahsoka who travel to the outer rim or like
Luke Skywalker who's in hiding in the outer rim
because even though this is taking place in the
mid Rim they let you know that there just aren't
a lot of Empire out here that's even more true in
the outer rim like the further out you go the
more space there is the harder it is for the
Empire to police that area so it just becomes
way easier for really important characters to
hide out in the outer rim the scrapyard seem like
they contains scraps from all kinds of Imperial
non-imperial ships I'm sure there's some Easter
eggs for Clone Wars stuff in the background too
like really old ships when he mentions all
these characters Jesse Fermi are his friends
Marvaa Fiona Shaw's character is kind of like his
surrogate mother becomes his surrogate mother the
Brasso character is his best friend that winds up
helping him Escape later in the episode the whole
idea is that this town is basically kind of like
a mining town but it's for the scrap yards like
everybody who lives here Works in and around
the scrap yards and the whole thing with this
elaborate lie that he creates with his Brasso
friend is just to show you some of the skills
he has in talking himself into situations and
out of situations like this like he's a real
fast talker engaged in a lot of spycraft so that's
why luthin wants him like oh you seem like the guy
I'm here to talk to the person with the special
skills that I need then we travel to morlano one
the planet where the corporate headquarters for
this party regular Corporation has their security
Force the true transports that you see flying in
the background the ones we also see later in the
episode 2 also seem similar to the designs from
the prequel movies like an evolution of the ones
from the prequel movies just a little bit smaller
but this whole scene is just meant to say that the
whole personality of the serial car and character
this inspector character who's kind of like the
inspector javer of the series to make a Les Mis
reference the guy that just like Won't Let It Go
like he's obsessed with finding Cassian Andor
obviously it becomes a bigger thing at the end
of episode three like it's now his life's mission
to find Cassian Andor if he seemed obsessed before
that's nothing compared to what it's going to
be like probably for the rest of the episodes
in all of his superiors dialogue is just meant
to get across the idea that the Empire is way
worse like however bad their corporation might
be like it seems like pretty big dirt bags the
Empire is way worse they don't want them getting
up in their business so they're just gonna brush
this little problem right under the rug obviously
by the end of episode 3 that goes out the window
like with all the attacks these explosions this
big fight that happens on the farrix planet the
Empire probably will will get involved but his
whole speech and a lot of what luthan says later
in the episode when cassian's whole speech about
how he's able to steal from the Empire is just
meant to hammer home the idea of how fat and lazy
the Empire has gotten in their superiority for the
last many years like they've been in power for
so long that the Empire has grown too big too
overconfident in the people within the Empire
that form the Rebellion use that against them
so his boss is meant to be like one example of a
bunch of different types of people all over the
Galaxy and explain how the rebellion was able to
use that against the empire because if everybody
was as hardcore as Karn and the other Sergeant
here it probably would have been way harder for
the Rebellion to actually form then we meet Adria
rona's biggest character who has this like weird
chemistry going on with casting Andor they aren't
together or anything like that but it seems like
that's going to change eventually she's a mechanic
who just seems like she's going to eventually help
Cassian in the formation of the Rebellion like
she's the contact that Luthen Rael uses for all
of his black market dealings and Cassian sort of
uses that to piggyback in to meet Luthen Cassian
also says he's going to come back to the planet
eventually he'll find some way and also in the
trailers you have the Imperial characters getting
involved on farrix with bix's character so it
seems like she's going to be a much bigger part
of the plot going forward as well and the way
they explain the star path unit that he's trying
to sell to Luthen Rael is it is a navigation unit
that allows them to track the movements of the
entire Imperial Fleet within like a giant part
of the Galaxy obviously very critical for a group
of people trying to create a rebellion because
they have to leave it in the warehouse at the end
of episode three we don't see anybody go back for
it Bix might wind up picking it up later like
it's still there we didn't see get crushed so
it still exists they had that whole drama with
her current boyfriend Timm that winds up selling
out casting Andor he gets his Just Desserts like
that's what you get for being a rat even though
they want you to sympathize with him just like a
little bit when he mentions wobani that's actually
one of the few Easter eggs in the episode it's an
Easter egg for rogue one and for Obi-Wan Kenobi
the name wobani is an anagram of Obi-Wan but is
also the exact same planet from the opening of
the Rogue 1 Movie it's the prison planet that
jyn urso was being held at they introduce you
to some of cassian's friends in and around the
town people that he owes money to just to give
you an idea for what his life has been like these
last several years until Luthen Rael recruits him
to help him form the Rebellion Cassian doesn't
have anything to do with the actual Rebellion or
the resistance he's just doing all these things to
try and track down his sister like that's why he's
running around all over the place borrowing money
from everyone as far as I can remember they don't
reference him having a sister during the events
of Rogue one at all so what might end up happening
by the end of this series maybe season one season
two he'll eventually find that sister like that's
his basic Arc in all this like he doesn't care
too much about the Rebellion right now he does
hate the Empire but he's not like Luthen Rael
he doesn't have grand plans all he wants is to
find his sister Luthen Rael sounds like the very
high-ranking Imperial figure who actually wants
to form the legit rebellion in the way they set
his character up it kind of seems like he's this
hidden figure that you didn't hear about before
like they wrote him into the Canon obviously for
the series but there trying to say that he's the
person who started everything like he's the person
who gave the idea to Mon mothma and then to bail
Organa like he's the person that got them on board
and then together they all worked to create the
Rebellion a couple side notes love the blue Ramen
looking noodles that this worker is eating the
Imperial census is from six years ago obviously
this is an older version of casting Andor than we
saw in the flashbacks but much younger than the
one that we see in present day the galactic census
would be the Empire trying to or attempting to
catalog every single person living in the Galaxy
but obviously obviously there are going to be
some gaps in their information like obviously
they missed Ahsoka they miss people like Luke
Skywalker he wouldn't be on that census you just
had to picture Darth Vader reading over the sense
it's like hmm Luke Skywalker that name sounds
familiar Skywalker where did I last hear that
name a couple different characters in the episode
reference chop as if he's like this really famous
person in the Galaxy or a deity that everybody
worships but the chob name is brand new into
the Star Wars Canon like they wrote it into this
series so you can let me know if you think it's
a really important person or like this deity that
a group of people worship and a lot of the stuff
that Cassian does like the really shady stuff or
him swapping ID logs and the ship here is just
to show you some of the spycraft skills that he
has that Luthen Rael wants so badly like oh wow
you're actually pretty good at this why don't you
come with me I need your help also love the Bell
worker like seems like he really really gets
into his job like all he does is just ring the
bell in the morning once and at the end of the
day to signify the end of work but he really
really gets into his job we finally meet the
Marvel character played by Fiona Shaw who most
of you will remember from the Harry Potter movies
she's the surrogate mother that winds up rescuing
him in the flashbacks when he went into the ship
to try and to destroy it and they do this funny
thing with casting andor's backstory where she
starts talking to him like how did they find out
that you were from kenari we didn't tell anybody
about that except we told a whole bunch of people
the reason why everybody thinks that he's from
Fest is because when the Rogue one movie came
out they said that he was from Fest so like
that's the way that the Star Wars people wrote
it into the Canon but I think what happened is
when they created the Andor series they wanted
to create this more dramatic attic backstory for
the character so they just explained that he'd
been lying this whole time and that's why there
were records of him being from Fest when really
he's from this kenari planet they introduced the
sergeant character love how trigger-happy is like
he and Karen together just want to go so overboard
trying to catch this one person how many people do
we need do you think a couple will be enough no we
better take like 12 maybe 14 people then when they
actually start flying to the fairix planet and
they're briefing the other officers it seems that
they're playing car and kind of like Lieutenant
Gorman from Aliens just with like a darker spin
on him look the super green higher ranking really
awkward person trying to do a bad job of leading a
bunch of more experienced grunts we finally meet
stellen skarsgard's Luthen Rael rail character
as far as I know he's just a really high ranking
Imperial figure they haven't completely explained
his backstory in the Star Wars Canon yet but I
think we'll learn about that in the next couple
of episodes and like I said he's the person who
has this grand plan in mind to form an actual
Rebellion so that's why he's dealing in all these
black market items like why he's willing to pay
so much money for this special Imperial control
unit so they can track all the Empire's movements
around all these sectors and they have that whole
speech with each other where they both kind of
explain the ethos and how the rebellion was able
to do what it did like the Empire is so fat and
lazy so overconfident it's so easy to steal from
them it's so easy to walk under their nose and get
away with all this stuff they also want to show
you how resourceful Luthen Rael's character is how
he's been able to get away with all this stuff for
so long being such a high-ranking figure inside
the Empire naturally you'd be heavily watched
so we'd have to be very good at what he did to
go for this long without being found out the whole
fight in the warehouse was great just the way they
filmed it the way it all went down but the even
funnier thing is when they get to drop on corn
all these inexperienced officers here he smashes
his calm because he literally just learned that
lesson from Luthen like Luthen Rael's like give me
your comp smashes it his friend from before also
winds up helping them Escape by tying out the
troop transport so that it winds up destroying
himself R.I.P to that grunt officer who went
back to get it and I think they went up taking
out most of their squad that they brought with
them through the course of of the episode with
all the different explosions but obviously these
first three episodes are just meant to show you
how Cassie and Andor got involved in the Rebellion
itself like the formation of the Rebellion it
hasn't actually become the Rebellion yet I still
think it's called The Resistance I believe in next
week's episode we'll see the empire for the first
time like there's a couple big Imperial characters
during the series I think we'll meet them in
next week's episode because of what happened
on the planet the big fire fight that they had
and we also might go back to Coruscant and see
mon mothma's character some of the other big
characters that'll be involved in the series
but if you spotted any other big Easter eggs or
references during the episodes that it didn't
talk about in the video just write down below
in the comments in general the series was built
to have fewer like direct references to like the
really big Star Wars stuff like we're not going
right back to Tatooine like ah we went back
to Tatooine again most of all this is meant
to be brand new stuff so like if it doesn't look
familiar that's on purpose but like we will see
mod mothma we'll go back to Coruscant we'll see
the Imperial Senate so there will be like a lot
of familiar stuff we'll see if like the Emperor
or a version of Princess Leia eventually shows
up I think the bail Organa will definitely show
up with the later episodes the episodes will be
one per week after this up to episode 12 in the
finale so my episode 4 video will post next week
after they release it I've got a bunch of other
big videos I'm working on this week my She-Hulk
video will post on Thursday I've got new Lord
of the Rings my house of the Dragon episode 6
video will post on Sunday so make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss all that
everyone click here for my house of the Dragon
Episode 6 trailer video and click here for my
Mandalorian season 3 trailer video Mandalorian
season 3 also starting in February big reminder
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!